make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this
is rob and we are back with x of swords
we're on part
technically i think this is part 14 i
know we can find combined two parts
together so i think we're
officially one behind uh what the
official numbering is but it doesn't
really matter uh we're still going in
order those are guys who are looking to
catch up you'll find the playlist down
in the description so you're not you
don't feel like you're kind of left out
and because i know we're covering a lot
of stories right now so a lot of you
guys may feel a little bit lost
uh check out the playlist down in the
description and that will give you
everything you need to get caught up on
the x-men
so uh what we end up doing here is we
pick up with the official start of the
tournament right the official start of
the duel
between krakowa and orocco and this
initially starts out with jubilee
resting alongside shogu right shogo
being a dragon that was once human in
form and all that kind of stuff anyway
she is kind of like her adopted kid more
or less but the idea is that in the
middle of taking this nap she's suddenly
met by a kind of telepathic message that
essentially tells her like there's not a
whole lot of time here
but in case you don't hear back from me
just know that things kind of went bad
right but i also care about you
now this of course this message is
coming directly from from betsy braddock
right the new captain britain kind of a
funny thing here and i don't think he
was given an official designation
until recently but brian braddock
because he doesn't really wield the
amulet of right instead and now he's
using this sort of might uh he's
basically captain avalon that's really
how that works now but the idea is that
of course this kind of telepathic
communication is cut off now jubilee
says
if i don't hear back from you by noon
like i'll come over there right i'll
come over there and find out what's
going on now of course the reason why
this message was cut off
is because betsy braddock was
interrupted you know talking to jubilee
by iska the unbeatable and so it's one
of these funny little things
because it's ka has this kind of
conversation where she talks to her
and says hey like you have the nine of
swords right like that's an ill omen
and it's kind of like you know when we
get out there uh you know it's not too
late for you to quit right it's not too
late for you to like give up if that's
what you choose to do and the response
of betsy brady is like that's not going
to happen right i'm not going to quit
like i'm not going to give up and it's
whole idea is like you shouldn't
embarrass yourself out there
right like i mean that doesn't need to
happen like just give up now while
everything's okay now keep in mind this
is not iska being kind and being
friendly
it's her basically taunting betsy
braddock right like you can't win
against me so the best thing for you to
do
is to give up right it should just quit
and it's one of these things where she
kind of says like of course it's not
going gonna happen and her response
is i'm just giving you some advice right
unbeatable is not just a name and and
the funny thing
is that when betsy asks iska like your
sword's called mercy right she's like
don't get excited that one
is just a name right so when we get out
there i'm not stopping against you like
i'm not holding back i'm gonna kill you
right because keep in mind this whole
tournament is for keeps right this is
this is a fight to the death that's what
every single one of these battles is and
so what we end up doing is picking up
with the official start of the
tournament with a handful of people from
other world here now
on the surface it kind of looks like man
there's like nobody here right like
nobody cares about this tournament the
reality of this is that it's being held
in such a way to where it's reminiscent
of
tournaments back during the era of of
like the dark age not really the dark
ages but like knights and kings and so
on and so forth that's how these kind of
tournaments were held right they were
relatively small get togethers different
things like that they weren't huge it
wasn't like the roman coliseums where
you would have thousands of people who
were there
all lining the stands they were never
really that big i guess hollywood's kind
of made it look like it was that big but
they were never really all that large in
the first place
the other thing here is that brian
braddock looks like the burger king guy
from those creepy burger king
commercials i just want to throw that
out there
that just needs to be said i am 100
confident in stating here
that was the intention
because he is kind of a creep and he is
a king and he loves burgers so i guess
it's only a matter of time before they
made him look like the burger king but
having said that
once iska and and betsy bradden come out
here right on the side of the gracoa
it's like come on betsy you got this you
got this right
but notice apocalypse he's just kind of
watching this whole thing go down
because he's kind of like okay
it's betsy braddock versus iska the
unbeatable
what's the likelihood she can actually
win here and then once the fight starts
right like you have apocalypse kind of
chimes in and says you know where
captain britain's like man she's got
this in the bag the response of of
apocalypse is well i've learned not to
underestimate
the the heart and trust like to trust in
the heart and the passion of young
people
but understand betsy braddock is not
that old right i mean she's not she's
not been around as a fighter for a very
long time she was a telepath she was an
x-man
sure she has the powers or the abilities
she had when she was quant for a little
while when she switched bodies with that
japanese ninja
but iska has been alive for centuries
her skills have been honed for centuries
this is a girl that does not have the
ability to lose
and has also been fighting with a sword
for longer than most
all of you have been alive right the
only person here that i would say has
been alive longer than isca or anywhere
close to however long isk has been alive
is apocalypse everybody else here every
single x-man every single
every single person from kakoa has been
alive that long right seemingly the
blink of an eye
and all of iska's lifespan and so when
that happens once the fight kicks off
things go kind of bonkers right because
you have betsy braddock who's sort of
intimidating a little bit and saying you
can't lose that just means you never
learned how to win a fight i never never
learned how to fight anybody at all and
this goes like okay cool let me prove
you wrong
she literally attacks and shatters the
swords of betsy braddock which in turn
shatters betsy braddock herself the
whole fight is over that fast like it
was literally
two hits right it was betsy braddock
hitting isca and then iska hitting betsy
braddock and then bessie braddock was
destroyed
just that fast and so from there
saturnine steps in and says the fight
really over that fast well that kind of
sucks like i mean i was expecting it to
be a little bit longer than that because
apparently she ended up showing up here
late now
a lot of you guys are going to look at
that and say that kind of sucks so the
fight is over that fast right there
should have been more to it than that
that's going to be a common theme not
because of the fact that jonathan
hickman is cheating us out of a story
but because there's actually some pretty
nefarious stuff going on here and we'll
find out more of what that looks like
here in a little bit but from here
we switch over to doug ramsey right over
to cypher and his card gets drawn which
means he's supposed to be ready to fight
but the response of saturnine
is like you know this little party that
we're having it's definitely going to be
a challenge
and your friend here better get used to
learning how to speak every language and
you better learn how to do it fast and
the reason why is because he's kind of
led away
by a handful by like three gorgeous
girls now i don't understand this
about cipher right he's literally being
led away by gorgeous girls and he's like
hey let go of me where are you taking me
guys help not me man if like if i were a
single man
and i was being led away by three
gorgeous girls i'd be like yes ladies
take me
but at the same time they also end up
taking one of the one of the fighters
from morocco's side and so when they
where you initially have like storm
maybe a couple people who interject and
say like we have to do something the
response of wolverine after that vision
that he saw because i had a lot of a
couple of you guys asking this question
um nothing that wolverine saw actually
came to fruition it was a glimpse of
what could happen if he actually did
kill saturnine or if krakow lost the
tournament right so it's just kind of a
glimpse there
so again it was all basically in his
head but you end up having you know
stormy kind of challenges that
wolverine's like no like we are not
going to turn against the rules if we
win this we have to win legit right
anything other than that and we will
it'll lead to the ruin of all and so
these girls are kind of kind of lead
cipher away
they leave this this other this other
chick away and then from there they take
him into
a kind of tent of sorts and it's kind of
nuts because ryan braddock looks to
apocalypse and he was like like
you had me worried that betsy braddock
would be humiliated not destroyed and
the responsible apocalypse is are you
really that stupid
we came here at a tournament that's
literally designed to to determine the
fate of our of our
dimensions and this is obviously a fight
to the death did you really believe that
nobody was gonna die
did you really believe that was gonna
happen brian braddock are you really
that dumb like it's it's kind of funny
right it's kind of hilarious he's like i
don't know why you ever thought this
journey would be without sacrifice
right some of us will return home
changed some of us will not return home
at all now this is an important thing to
understand here because remember with
betsy braddock basically being destroyed
more or less that means if they try to
resurrect her
in krakowa that she'll come back a
different version of herself right
this is this is one of the things that i
mentioned when they previously
introduced this at the very beginning of
extra swords this is a way for marvel to
soft reboot right and that's what we see
happening a lot right over the years of
marvel comics those guys who
don't really get that over the years of
marvel comics their way of rebooting was
totally different from dc's
dc would not really soft reboot
characters they would hard reboot right
they would do event like crisis on
infinite earth they would do
something like like infinite crisis or
new 52 which honestly
crisis on infinite earths and the new 52
are the only times that dc really hard
rebooted their entire landscape
uh but what you'll get after those are
mini crises right so you've got crisis
on defending earth and then you got zero
hour then you got
infinite crisis and you got final crisis
those were designed to basically
fix plot threads that have been left
over after the events of uh of christ
on infinite earth you also get stories
like black estate brightest night and
the green lantern mythos that was a soft
reboot right you get these small little
things that are done here and there in
dc
to kind of bring small things back or
change characters or something along
those lines
and marvel that's all they do marvel
never hard reboots right marvel's never
had an instance in the history of their
publication line
when it was like you know marvel number
zero or you know spider-man number zero
and this guy number zero
iron man number zero and captain america
number zero and it was just a line-wide
reboot that's never happened i think
it's a problem that's never happened but
that's never actually happened instead
what marvel does is stuff like this
right so if mama if jonathan hickman
wants to rework you know
betsy brady if you look at her character
and he says okay over the years
she's kind of grown stagnant and her
history has been really weird and really
shuffled and it's kind of been a hassle
to follow because it has
right is anybody let me tell you
something man anybody who knows anything
about the publication history or even
the just the end universe history of
betsy braddock will tell you
it's a hassle right it's an absolute
nightmare to understand that uh but if
hickman sits down and looks at that and
says yeah
we should rework betsy braddock this is
the way they do it right she dies here
in other world which means that they
can't bring her back the way she was
when they resurrect her it'll just be
some random version from of herself from
across the the multiverse which means
whatever version we get is gonna more or
less be a soft rebooted character she's
gonna have a whole new history and all
that kind of stuff right she's gonna
have to learn to probably reintegrate
herself back into the x-men things are
going to be different we might even get
kind of a little bit of history of her
own universe along the way but whatever
it is she's going to come out different
than she was before the only exception
to that is if she somehow reconstituted
her the way she was and nothing's
changed at all right but if she stays
dead and they resurrect you in kokoa
then it'll be a soft reboot of our
character
right so just kind of something to keep
in mind now where douglas ramsay is led
away
right this other person from morocco
that's led away is a woman called they
the blood moon and the idea behind this
is that bae has a set of powers that are
almost identical to the powers
of black bull of the inhumans right then
what she can do is she can basically
release something called a doom note and
this is essentially just a giant
concussive force of energy that comes
out of her mouth in the form of her
voice
but what she's learned is that over over
time it's not
necessarily just like black bolt right
in the sense that when black bolt speaks
he's got a quasi-sonic screen so he
cannot talk and not scream at the same
time
the only way for him to do that is to
like transition his essence to a
different realm or for doctor strange to
create some kind of pocket place where
he can talk and his powers are
neutralized or something along those
lines but if he's just walking down the
street on earth or traveling anywhere
within the normal universe in
in the main marvel universe if he talks
he's gonna kill somebody with
with uh with bae what she learned is she
has that power but she can also talk at
the same time so she can channel at any
point in time so think of it like a
vocal version
of cyclops optic glass when he's wearing
his
optic visor right that he can look
around when he has his optic visor on
but he can also channel his powers if he
wants to at the same time that's kind of
how that works
and so because of this uh one of the
things that goes on with this doom note
is that it works
a little uniquely with doug ramsey in
the sense that doug has the ability to
understand
any language but he can't understand
hers because hers
is a language that doesn't exist within
the main marvel universe right i mean i
guess it does but a rocco has been so
far removed from anything in the main
marvel universe it's a language
nobody in the universe has ever
encountered before and so because of
that the doom note itself the the kind
of power
in the voice of bei desires to be
understood
right it wants to be it wants somebody
to to hear it and to understand what
it's saying but the the words she speaks
are not really a true language and she
cannot it cannot really be translated
and so it's almost kind of like this
vocal slash linguistics
version of a an immovable force meaning
an unstoppable object that kind of a
thing
it's it's kind of crazy you know with
this this little bit of a thing here but
the whole reason why
they're being brought together is really
kind of brought to bear when you have
uh magic visiting doug and the two of
them kind of start talking about what's
going on and he's like i have no idea
what's happening like what's what's
going on right here she's like well
ryan's pretty inconsolable he's pretty
pissed off and everybody else is as well
uh they're just kind of you know
mingling with the the iraqi people a
little bit more but no one really feels
friendly towards isca where they're all
kind of pissed off at her because she
killed betsy
but uh as they as the doors open and
they start to step in
that doug realizes oh my god like bae's
not gonna kill me in a tournament she's
gonna marry me like it's literally a
marriage that's kind of been assembled
here now here's the funny thing about
this
right teeny howard plays this fast and
loose it's just kind of like okay
like doug's like all right cool i'm
gonna get married now here's the thing
man right like you see the two of them
standing next to each other this is a
big woman
right and not terms not in terms of
girth but just in terms of like physical
size
she's like what maybe like two heads
taller than than douglas ramsey right
she's got maybe like a foot on him all
right let me tell you something cipher
she's gonna make a man out of you
man okay yes she is
she's gonna man she's gonna make a meal
out of him you better be ready but
uh but nonetheless it's kind of a crazy
thing because the time comes for them to
like make their vows and he's like i
mean i didn't prepare any vows and
saturn is like well then you better
prepare him you better you better do a
quick fast and in a hurry and he
actually makes these
pretty amazing vows on the fly right he
says bay the blood moon right this is a
little absurd because i don't know
anything about you but you're gonna be
my wife so i swear to uphold my vow to
you for the duration of this
challenge or whatever right however long
it goes after and i'll always be
grateful that we got to do this instead
of sword fight because i'm not really
ready to die
[Laughter]
they're not bad vows right now in
response to that uh
bae offers her vows which are really
good as well right she says like when
the grim
fog of bloodshed overtakes us the
beloved is the beacon that returns us to
our better selves love is a failed he
that cannot be broken
i will love you with the force of the
wave that crashes the shore
like the current that swallows the sand
it's kind of cool it's pretty
interesting and so he's kind of like i
mean i don't really understand anything
you said
this is really really fascinating and
then she pulls she pulls back the veil
and uh and doug's like man she's super
hot right so he just immediately swept
up and how gorgeous this girl is and so
from there like in the middle of this
wedding fire just goes everywhere fire
just gets sprayed everywhere and here
comes jubilee riding shogo
and everybody's like jubilee what are
you doing like what are you doing here
like you're flying in here with a dragon
like here comes a clue train jubilee
the last stop is you this is not a good
idea
you should not do this you should not
fly in here with a dragon
and start breathing fire everywhere but
jubilee is like well i told
betsy braddock if i didn't hear from her
by 12 that i'd come over here and see
what's going on now here's the crazy
thing about this is keep in mind
shogo's dragon fire in otherworld has
the ability to melt that reality right
he can literally destroy
the physical principles of that reality
and so when when you have you know
wolverine who's kind of like hey man
that's kind of cool this dragon's coming
here and he's going to burn the place
down
the response of apocalypse is no that's
not cool at all wolverine that is not by
any means
a cool thing i mean maybe a little bit
maybe it's like a little bit cool but
it's not as cool as you're making it out
to be right because this dragon
will destroy the reality in which we
live right and we will all
perish along with it right so killing us
is the least of what this dragon can do
it's kind of a cool little a cool little
thing there now while all that's going
on
uh cypher is kind of like okay like he's
talking to beijing are you gonna go out
there she's and she doesn't really say
anything
like are you really gonna go out there
are you really gonna you're really gonna
do all this but like i mean if you do
here's the thing
like don't kill like don't kill the
dragon the dragon's cool it's like a
little baby right like the dragon's cool
like don't kill the dragon she
immediately turns around and kisses him
right so here's here's what i'm gonna
bet right i'm gonna bet this here and
i'll tell you what if i'm wrong
i will give out three rob core rings
right i will give three rob core rings
for
free which by the way full of you guys
who are asking uh we're gonna start
selling them i'll make an announcement
later but i'll give out three rob core
rings for free what i'm willing to bet
here
is that the time is going to come when
it's time for cypher to fight and she's
going to fight in his stead
in every single match that he has that i
doubt the two of them are actually going
to have to fight each other and if they
do have to fight each other she'll
sacrifice her life for him and then
cipher will basically be the one who
wins the tournament he'll come out on
top and he'll be the one that says
saves krakow i will bet that i will bet
that's exactly what happens i don't know
if it is
but i will bet that's what happens now
the cool thing is that once saturday
shows up here and realizes what's going
on
she's pissed right she's she's eight
kinds of pissed off right just she's
she's
mad as hell when she comes she comes
walking out here
and she's like no like this is not gonna
fly and it's one of the well no pun
intended but it's one of those things
where like she almost intends to destroy
it
but then you have wolverine who kind of
chimes in like that baby's gonna hurt
storm right and that's when saturday
realizes oh that's right it's a baby so
she uses her magic and then manipulates
the mind of shogo
in order to bring him to her and bring
him under her spell right she also kind
of just dissipates his dragon fire so it
can't really destroy
anything inside of anything inside of
other world but it's one of these things
where she makes this comment where she
was like you know it's lucky that i'm in
a good mood today right because
if if you had actually flown jubilee
here i would have killed her in front of
everybody but i would have killed her in
front of every single person here and so
it's a little bit
a little bit nuts because from there you
know once everything kind of settles
down that it's like okay she's like i'm
in a good mood but i got my drinks we
got a wedding we have cake right
one point for each side right like one
point for each person
and that's where it ends so in the first
match right the first day of this battle
which i won't even lie this story kind
of went off the rails and the first day
of this battle
uh betsy braddock died in two hits and
oh really just with one hit
and cipher got married to a chick he
doesn't know so yeah
that's kind of where we are now here's
the crazy thing about this it's only
going to get crazier but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you